aquí tenemos una curva que representa la
función
fx y tenemos un problema clásico que los
matemáticos conocen desde hace mucho
tiempo como encontramos el área bajo
esta curva entre la curva y el eje x y
entre un par de límites entre x iguala y
x igual a b vamos a dibujar estos
límites aquí está el límite izquierdo y
aquí está el límite derecho nos interesa
esta área que estoy señalando sin usar
cálculo podemos tener cada vez mejores
aproximaciones para encontrar esta área
como lo hacemos podemos dividir esto en
varias secciones delta x desde a ave
pueden ser secciones iguales o no pero
para visualizarlo mejor vamos a dibujar
secciones más o menos iguales aquí
tenemos una sección aquí la segunda aquí
la tercera aquí la cuarta aquí la quinta
y aquí la sexta estas secciones delta x1
esta es delta x2 esta delta x 3 hasta
llegar al delta x
ahora trataremos de sumar las áreas de
los rectángulos para encontrar el área
bajo la curva para hacer esto
necesitamos calcular la altura de los
lados de cada rectángulo y para eso
vamos a usar el valor de la función f x
del lado derecho de cada rectángulo
aunque podría ser cualquier punto dentro
de la delta x como la altura que les
corresponde esta es una solución y
veremos más detalles de esto en futuros
vídeos hacemos esto y ahora tenemos una
aproximación el área de cada uno de
estos rectángulos va a ser f x subíndice
y que es el lado derecho de cada
rectángulo x delta x y después sumamos
todas estas áreas y tendremos una
aproximación del área total pero siempre
que tengamos un número finito de
rectángulos siempre podremos mejorar
nuestra aproximación haciendo más
pequeña
nuestra delta x para tener más de estos
rectángulos aquí tenemos la suma que va
de igual a 1 hasta n pero qué pasa si
delta x se vuelve cada vez más delgada
n se vuelve cada vez más grande conforme
delta x se vuelve infinitesimalmente
pequeña y conforme n se aproxima a
infinito pueden darse cuenta de que esto
se parece al límite cuando n tiende a
infinito o al límite cuando delta x se
vuelve infinitamente más pequeña esta
noción de que nuestra aproximación
mejora conforme nos acercamos al límite
cuando n tiende a infinito es la idea
central detrás del cálculo integral se
llama cálculo integral porque la
operación central que usamos la suma de
un número infinito de cosas
infinitesimalmente pequeñas es la
integral esto es la integral de a a b
aprenderemos los detalles más adelante
pero en este caso esto es una integral
definida de fx de x pueden ver aquí las
similitudes podemos ver el símbolo de
integral como la anotación sigma de esta
suma pero en lugar de sumar un número
discreto de elementos vamos a sumar un
número infinito de elementos
infinitamente delgados
tener delta x tenemos de equis cosas
infinitesimalmente delgadas
esta es la noción de una integral lo que
hace interesante al cálculo además de
usar esta noción del límite es estar
conectado a la noción de la derivada lo
que lo hace aún más poderoso es una de
las cosas más bellas en matemáticas como
veremos en el teorema fundamental del
cálculo la integración o noción de
integrar está muy relacionado con la
noción de la derivada de hecho con la
noción de la anti derivada en el cálculo
diferencial teníamos problemas que
decían tenemos una función y podemos
encontrar su derivada en el cálculo
integral decimos si comenzamos con la
derivada podremos encontrar su
integración podremos encontrar su anti
derivada o la función de la cual es
derivada veremos que todas estas ideas
están relacionadas
la idea del área bajo la curva la idea
del límite de la suma de un número
infinito de cosas infinitesimalmente
delgadas y la noción de la anti d
se unen en nuestro viaje al cálculo
integral y con esto terminamos